Wisconsin high school students marching
for gun reform are expected to finish a
50 mile journey this morning the 40
students began to march over the weekend
in Madison they'll finish today in
Janesville that's where House Speaker
Paul Ryan lives students will hold a
rally there to pressure Congress to take
action on gun control
after the Parkland school shooting
Adriana Diaz is in Janesville with their
goals Adriana good morning good morning
the students will arrive at this
Janesville Park in a few hours for their
rally now they chose it because they'll
have to cross that bridge by foot to get
here reminiscent of Martin Luther King's
march from Selma the students are coming
here because they want speaker Ryan to
act student voices reverberating through
Wisconsin's usually serene farmland
Tuesday at every mile they honored a
victim of gun violence we met them on
the final stretch of their 50 mile march
how do you think dozens of young people
marching in a very rural area I don't
even see a house so no one's hearing you
necessarily right now how do you think
that translates into action people can
hear us people can hear us from every
corner of the country and that's the
power of you know social media their
destination is Janesville the hometown
of House Speaker Paul Ryan she has more
influence over how people vote why
people vote we have unique opportunity
of being in his home state speaker
Ryan's currently overseas and in a
statement his office said he respects
those expressing their views after the
Stoneman Douglas High School shooting
last month Ryan oversaw the passage of
legislation making background checks
more comprehensive it's a step in the
right direction is what I go in I'd say
it's a very small stuff the students
want a ban on civilian owned
military-style weapons and bump stocks a
four day waiting period and background
checks for all gun purchases and to
raise the buying age to 21 but broad gun
reform may be difficult in a recent Pew
report the NRA counted nearly 400
pro-gun bills enacted in states since
2013 do you know what you're up against
here we do the politicians the NRA
they're powerful people but it's not
just an array it's a lot of America
who feel that it's important to protect
gun rights we're not saying that we are
right you know we're not saying that
we're the only opinion that matters what
we're asking for is a seat at the table
the NRA didn't respond to our request
for comment about the students proposals
now we asked the marchers what's next
and they said they're calling for
students in every state to hold their
own 50-mile marches Anthony Adriana Diaz
thanks Adriana